Welcome back everyone The Witcher dropped a new
season three teaser so we'll break it down there
was a big post credit scene at the end of blood
origin meant to be a teaser for The Witcher season
3 I'll explain what it means because there's a
bunch of time travel now which is part of the
books that they're adapting in what books they
are adapting for season three like the next
part of the story that they're doing for season
three and all the changes that they introduced
to the series backstory during blood origin and
how that's going to affect the show's ending as
well as their announced ending for Henry cavill's
character because it sounds like they're actually
gonna kill him off and they'll be a big twist
that will explain why he looks like Liam Hemsworth
during season four as confusing as that all sounds
I will try to explain what's going on as well as
why Henry Cavill left The Witcher because there's
a bunch of stuff going on in his life too good
things mostly even though there were a bunch of
left turns this past year that he probably didn't
expect either if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of big stuff coming up in January like The Last of
Us series on HBO more trailers for Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania the Mandalorian season season 3
there's a bunch of big stuff happening of course
I will do videos for everything many thanks to
this week's sponsors raid Shadow Legends raid
Shadow Legends is one of the biggest mobile games
in the world right now that's totally free to play
that's right it's free They just added a legendary
champion based on MMA Superstar Ronda Rousey with
fighting moves based on her real-life MMA fighting
techniques within the lure of the game Ronda is
part of the banner Lords faction born to a lesser
house but gaining Fame in the fighting pits
eventually becoming Queen of the Arena you can get
Ronda for free right now whether you're a new or a
long time player just by logging into raid all you
have to do is log in and play raid for seven days
between now and February 28th and to celebrate
Ronda's arrival in raid use the special promo
code raid Ronda I'll put it on screen here to get
a bunch of helpful stuff perfect for leveling up
Ronda so she's at the top of her game because it's
the holidays they're also celebrating the 12 days
of raid all you have to do is download raid Shadow
legends from the links below copy in your player
ID from in-game and then using the special link
think that I'll put on screen here https 12 days
of raid plarium.com enter your player ID to start
the 12-day event between December 19th and January
10th and each day experience a new chapter of the
holiday story and you can play a new Mini-Game
for a chance to win in-game and real life prizes
including holiday themed raid Champions and Amazon
gift cards worth up to a thousand dollars and
for existing players you can head to that same
12 days of raid link to get a special promo code
for holiday gift new players use my link or scan
the QR code right here and get a free starter
pack with this loot you can find the rewards
here in your inbox within the next 30 days only so
be sure to check it out careful for spoilers for
The Witcher blood origin if you haven't watched
those episodes but during the series we see the
origin of couple key players later in the timeline
who become much bigger part later in The Witcher
story of present day in the main show that we'll
see during season three primarily aired into the
wild Hunt the Mage avalak the white Frost who
now they're saying is an actual purse not just
a force of nature coming to destroy the planet and
every other planet eventually and ciri's ability
to time travel using her power in combination
with the monoliths as crazy as time travel sounds
in the universe of The Witcher time travel is a
thing in the book so like they are adapting that
part of the books although they have made some
changes to the way the story plays out one of
the big twists of The Witcher Universe from the
books the video games is it isn't just a basic
fantasy story swords and sorcery is actually more
SCI fantasy the way that Star Wars is Sci fantasy
issues that you don't find out about that till
the later books in the video games we also saw
the origin of the witchers during blood origin
but we kind of already knew what witchers were
what their role was in the story all the biggest
changes of the book story in the games which come
after the books in the timeline are mostly to
ciri's story so when I talk about the changes
to the books and how that's going to affect
the story it's mostly about how it's going
to affect series story towards the end so for
instance during The Witcher 3 we see the end of
serious story she faces the white Frost I think
some of the changes they made are in service of
changes on the show that they'll make to the way
that that goes down the way she faces the white
Frost and we also have to address that they are
making The Witcher 4 game so like they will write
more story after that even though series ending in
The Witcher 3 was originally meant to be a final
ending but the way they wrote her dealing with
the white Frost but the game was so successful
it earned so much money it's an amazing game if
you haven't played it you should check it out
they just did a big HD remaster and they're going
to remaster the original games too they would have
been stupid to not try and write more story after
that but we won't find out what the new game is
going to be like what that new story is for like
another two or three years because it's going to
take them a long time to release it and by then
The Witcher TV story The Witcher Netflix will
likely have ended its run given everything that's
been going on with the show in real life I think
they originally planned on going five seasons
based on the book material with like a little
bit of video game stuff added in maybe Seven
Seasons with a bunch of video game story added
in but that was a couple years ago when they were
saying this and that was when I think they plan to
have Henry Cavill playing geralt the end entire
time so we think all their plans for the show
had just accelerated a bunch and they're only
going to make it about Five Seasons maybe only
four depending on how season three goes gonna
be real hard to get people to watch that show
after Henry Cavill leaves and if it wasn't clear
season three is Henry cavill's final season as
the character like they've already filmed season
three he's in every episode then per the show's
statement per Netflix's statement they're treating
it more like a doctor who style twist recasting
with Liam Hemsworth and I think that time travel
on the show might be a key to how that goes down
based on their uses of the Doctor Who reference
like Doctor Who is a time travel show why would
you reference Doctor Who if it wasn't going to
be a time travel twist and why would you make
your season 3 teaser a time travel teaser if it
weren't going to be a big part of season three
but in that Witcher season 3 post credit scene
avalak uses the book of monoliths that he's stolen
from Baylor to time travel back to the events
of season one of the main show before ciri had
met geralt before Emperor emhyr had shown up her
father Sack cintra at a bid to try and recapture
her so avalock isn't meant to be really evil the
same way that a lot of the other characters seem
like they're evil like Emperor Emhyr the white
Frost villain aired in the wildhood but to be fair
there is no real main villain on The Witcher
like the white Frost is technically meant to
be like the biggest villain but everyone on
the show is meant to be low-grade kind of a
terrible person so it's like a bunch of terrible
people trying to do what they think is right all
going up against each other with differing
opinions on things so you have ciri stuck in
the Middle she's this Ultra powerful being who
isn't totally capable of Defending herself yet
geralt who's trying to help her survive and then
all these other factions that just want her for
their own reasons avalak for example is one of
those different factions her father Emperor Emhyr
wants to use her power to help conquer the rest
of the continent because he's been doing that for
the past couple of years in the background of
the show like he's slowly been conquering all
the other realms vilgefortz who's also one of the
antagonists wants her power to have another child
to fulfill this big prophecy that will give birth
to an even more powerful child that he can control
Eredin and the wild Hunt want her so they can
open as many gates as they want Between Worlds
conquering them across time and space because
he's basically stranded on this other arid world
and they need her power to open the gates again
so that he can travel between worlds there are
space unicorns in the universe of The Witcher
that can open gates the way that ciri does but
aired in across time across the hundreds and
hundreds of years up to present day has wound
up killing all them off using them to travel
between worlds so that's why he needs ciri now
because there are no more space unicorns for
him to kill we'll see how the show addresses
that and it seems like the white Frost villain at
least the way they change things during the blood
origin series is manipulating everyone like even
manipulating iridin the wild Hunt because they
want more chaos magic like the whole idea is they
just absorb Magic from other powerful beings and
I think part of the idea is that the Arid world is
other world that Eredin is stranded on used to be
green and Lush but this other person absorbed all
the power there and turned it into an arid world
and now she's going to come to the main world
and do the same thing to it and that's going
to be the Fulfillment of ifling ultimate prophecy
the prophecy about her defeating the white Frost
that you see in the books in the games which is
where we get to a bunch of our changes I think
part of the idea is that they wanted ciri to have
a fight at the end of the show like whatever the
final season is with the white Frost defeating
in but her fighting an actual person instead of
just like fighting a giant white cloud of winter
because in the books and the games the way they
personify the white Frost is more like a force of
nature like there's no actual Consciousness to it
the way the TV show is setting it up it might wind
up being an actual person who's just another time
traveler pretending to be someone else like why
does the white Frost speak with a Scottish accent
in the exact same language that Eredin and all the
other Elven characters can understand if it's not
another Elven character from their race that's
been time traveling avelak also wants ciri but
his stance on her changes throughout his story
like he seems like kind of an antagonist later
on but he actually winds up helping her defeat
the white Frost where we see him here staring
at her he's at the beginning of his story he's a
little more naive about things you have to imagine
a couple hundred years later he'll be a little bit
more bitter about all all this stuff The Witcher
season 3 episode 1 is titled Shaerrawedd it's an
ancient Elven Palace in this area of forest that's
sacred to the elves that was this big fortress to
them about 200 years ago before it was destroyed
by humans it means that during episode 1 geralt
and Ciri are going to be riding through it like
they were in The Blood of Elves book and Blood of
Elves is the book that they're largely adapting
for the story of season three Legacy with some
changes the title of Blood of Elves is also a
reference to series Elder blood because it
is Elven but it started with the elves she
is part elf the title is also referenced to the
dying of the elves the fate of the elves losing
their battle fighting with Emperor Emhyr the other
humans in the continent they're slowly dying out
and that was part of the Jaskier and the minnie
driver scenes during blood origin she said that
she wanted him to recite the tale of the seven
the origin of the Elder blood the wild Hunt the
white Frost the order of witchers in order to
inspire The Elves and within the elves you have
a group of them that wants to live peacefully and
leave the humans alone and just kind of continue
living out their lives slowly dying out and then
another group of them did more militant and wants
to kill all the humans when he goes back at the
end of blood origin is saved from the temerians
the elves probably eventually take him back
to this area near the woods near the Sherwood
which might be where he runs into geralt again
in present day during season three she's still
trained to be a Witcher not much time has gone
by but she's also been training in her magecraft
learning to use her magic powers through Elder
blood like she started to open gates at the end
of season two she'll continue to learn more about
that which is where I think we get to the idea of
her using the gates to time travel we'll learn
more about vilgefortz working with Emperor Emhyr
even though both of them have their own agendas
for wanting ciri eventually geralt helps ciri to
become powerful enough to protect herself and
make her own decisions about what she wants to
do and be less of a pawn to these other factions
and the way they tease this time travel twist in
Henry Cavill having a heroic going out at the end
of the show like we'll give him a Heroes ending
makes it sound like something crazy is going to
happen and she'll use her power to time travel
at the end of season 3 either on purpose or on
accident and that might be how they explain Henry
level looking like Liam Hemsworth but being the
same character like she might just see geralt
earlier in his timeline even though in real life
Liam Hemsworth is only about seven years younger
than Henry Cavill but because he's way less swole
it is a lot easier to pass him off as the much
younger version of geralt earlier in his timeline
and that might be why they use Doctor Who when
they were trying to explain the recasting there
is the whole Doctor Who Regeneration twist like
that is how actors on Doctor Who change with the
character being the same but I think it's harder
to explain Garrett looking completely different
just because he's almost destroyed and ciri
magically heals him with her power but in doing
so changes his appearance somehow that feels even
more ridiculous than ciri just time traveling and
seeing a younger version of geralt let me know in
the comments though how do you think they're going
to explain the recasting because the showrunner
did say during season three they give Geralt
the very heroic ending making it sound like he
either dies trying to protect her or something
terrible happens to him setting up the need for
ciri to use her power and when she sees him again
she's either changed him or she's traveled back in
time in its younger girl from before he died but I
think part of the reason why he left has something
to do with his original plans for what was going
to happen with Superman the Superman movies that
he thought that he was going to be making because
remember they revealed that he had actually talked
about leaving the show as early as season two
so it had been in the works for a while Amazon
just announced they picked up his Warhammer series
that he's going to be producing and starring in so
it sounds like up to about October of this year
he thought that he was going to be much busier
playing a version of Superman in the movies the
DC movies and doing this Warhammer TV series then
by November they hired James Gunn and he wants
to do a complete reboot of DC movies and Henry
Cavill is out so even though it does suck that
he's not going to play Superman anymore I'm sure
the Warhammer series that he does is going to look
really cool I've already done a big trailer video
for because he released this big teaser and tried
to explain exactly how it's going to play out
because it'll be Warhammer TV series and Warhammer
movies everyone click here for his Warhammer
trailer video and click here to learn about Ben
Affleck coming back to play another character
at Marvel thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!